like sausage from what from trying to
think this game yeah apparently we had
some nap type problems that we resolved
if you're on the wrong that like won't
let you connect like sitting right next
to you but I wouldn't let us come next
to the same game so make sense now do
you want to roll with you haven't been
using a handgun and debating and not
taking a machine gun so I can give you
all the machine gun ammo that's cool
hand it over um I think I'll do that I
just sell it no ye
dang of goods you feel good mmm oh wait
let's Bosh I have a lot of money but I
still just don't know this I've been
using that handgun there's a stun rod
yeah I got one of those sorry uh no I
don't just all right here I'm going to
lower my chairman there we go sure
enough already
um I'm going to get uh handguns new
handgun not that expensive
I'll pay the [ __ ] out of it I want
anything I could upgrade my things Jen
[Music]
it's always nice to increase like
firepower and spend a lot of money in
the [ __ ]
um what on upgrading just this weapon in
general
all right I'm ready as ever you are just
now people that comments have been
saying maybe we should alternate these
like whose point of view it's from but
figured in keeping with the spirit of
Resident Knievel because it's your first
time through most of these games we're
gonna keep it from Chris Redfield okay
Mary Kish Knievel's perspective yeah but
if you guys are like really stoked on
seeing that keep letting us know in the
comments as we can do it I just didn't
know how big of a deal was yeah way more
fun to watch shows me what we've been
avoiding is like just switching back and
forth only because we can save a lot of
time not doing that there's handgun ammo
over here sorry didn't mean that don't
start doing that
I forget how I just picked up a beast
slate or a part of it so we gotta go
searching for those I'll take that and
go thank you all right
gonna come on the boat right now come on
now you Raja you know yeah
wait oh you're totally right thank you I
think there's actually one over here too
maybe here you not anything nope all
right sweet did you read that guy's dead
corpse
yeah something so before I didn't go
very far but when we were trying to get
the connection working I was like
messing around in that area that's why I
knew that there was stuff there I'm
driving
Oh what am i doing okay full speed ahead
dum-dum no spots no shove us the driver
mean
it's probably what people want to see
your perspective that's it like
hurry shava shava shava hurry hurry
Shover enough of all come on shovel
I will turn the gameplay Audio
completely off keep doing that next let
me do it
yes I'm doing
I'm just staring at you the whole time
ah well then you're both immune got a
check points and we have map oh yeah we
gotta go at the other pieces the slate
now look at don't go
I want to drive
I don't know if there's nothing worth
exploring a time up here but right now
I'm just gonna go to the come on right
now I'm just gonna go to the the
objective stop that you do know that
can't hear it right I know I know you
know actually they still like it please
stop it's actually annoying me I'm
serious oh no triggering my misophonia
of buttons no like noises consistent
annoying noises you're gonna to let that
go I wish I could that take those pears
pears yeah document shooting an enemy
will give you an opening to get close
enough to fight it directly well duh
we've been here for a while yeah
couldn't tell judging by the way you
play oh alright umm just got some medal
yeah that's a weird time for them to
tell you that because we've been I've
been hitting all sorts of dudes all the
time this may be something worthwhile
miss JA him get him oh sweet red hot
that is
all these pots are the exact same
there's a chicken in here Oh picots egg
up oh sorry no egg Jose you got some
target practice though
alright about the triggers something I
think or in a little bit can't do an egg
run under these conditions lots of money
but not a lot I am oh are you able to
give me your a my uh what kind you need
all I have is rifle and handgun um if
you need rifle eventually I can give it
to you but I don't need assassin here
that's all I actually need you did Oh
Minh a system get up there girl fight
that awful noise and beasts late we got
some people come in shop slave wow that
was sudden super predict don't touch our
slate hey is it chicken shoot that one
first the channel umm so I'm up here I'm
just gonna snipe all infected or we get
run to the boat maybe
oh [ __ ] just like the document shoot me
yeah
killing if he did with my riffle no I'm
just like shooting these four people hey
you look good there's not many people
left gonna kill a lot of them okay yeah
I'll go get their ammo before they out
and money before that Fiskars well got
it
stomp Wow oh just dick dick up you did
oh [ __ ] is he gonna do it again what is
with these
wait wait what are you doing there still
oh and I was stomping that guy time in
place I don't understand
get stomped
Oh guys super-dead shotgun shells you
have a shotgun right yeah yeah wait I
don't know yeah oh I tried to just try
to hit that guy and I miss Oh what what
was that a - you have a shotgun
yeah you Wow I gotta heal you I don't
have any healing ud idea
yeah I'll cover you just peel should we
be going toward the bow at this point
now we're getting annoying room
whoops don't pick that up did you want
some of this he'll um
I'll wait for you I'm all right
he might as well I might as well be near
yeah I don't want thinking from us
that's what happens what do you mean I
don't think you like suck it out it's
like I don't think you're like I thought
it did I'm thinking you're like
breathing in my hair stealing your
oxygen sucking up all the useful air
uh-huh you hit this like hanging rat
with your face your face is overhanging
rat you wanna drive yes okay well tough
okay wait did I guess it just knows I'm
gonna be the better driver switch spot
man come on stop that oh my god so
there'd it's yeah I did it you know
we're going I don't know driver to the
backs on the right oh okay
[Music]
oh god I wish I could kill you and
whence you fire here we go I did it
square I'm a good driver Oh a lot of
water here
oh yeah there's alligators - really no
oh [ __ ] yes there is yes sir let's just
go back go back go back go back go back
go back
what I'm pretty sure they're alligators
here I just forget how to what yeah
they're not huh what do we do you just
run it or I guess so hurry though
there's an alligator right there shoot
it shoot it shoot it no goddamn it just
run no just run just run [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it
there's multiple Jinyu what's the drive
both and gets eaten right after what
that was scary
I hate animals that's a Michigan oh I
don't need Dion's him yes you go Miami
we're good were good were good we're
good we're good
sweet oh my gosh that was scary
oh we're right here just run
he came from that direction the one that
killed me you can outrun there's a bunch
there's more than two I think just run
towards that height on the other side oh
I don't like it
I run under the hut there's a ladder if
you see that oh I was looking at your
screen sorry
people watching about that scream oh my
god that's terrifying
you all right sweet we are I'm sure we
could waste animal killing them both
this is funner more fun um what do you
have in terms of healing eyes okay
nothing let's back out of here like a
little bit okay
come through this window
sweetie I wonder you come to eating your
red herb you can take I think I don't
need it
you have a green I have a red I thought
oh that's a shame yeah um oh there's neg
edgren ed this is a harder game do an
egg run in oh it takes up as much space
as like a rifle that should have hurt
you but um
should we try and do an egg run I guess
should I just take an egg and sure let's
try it
that just results all right here we go
I'm more difficult game for you yeah
whatever find it okay
hi we're doing an egg run oh crap I
didn't mean to take that where are you
I'm in this Hut that's where the still
did you the slate nice punch
hang it from the logic he's not that bad
I'm gonna tell him oh no come on I'm
coming
oh he's dead he is dead [ __ ] shells
wait I have stuff for you thank you come
on
save it shotgun us right there's an
alligator action no I [ __ ] I
originally I really am uncomfortable
with that kind of stuff that stuff like
genuinely scares me water creatures yeah
I have like nightmares every once in a
while about being in like waist deep
deep water with a creature on pressed by
your fears did you go down the ladder
yep and I also got a [ __ ] Ruby on the
way
he's right there about it oh [ __ ]
forever they're easy to dodge just go
like stay away from his mouth
mmm really fine fine I'm here I'm here
where shoot them if they get near me I
will mark let me drive Joe drive why
does it make me there you go
you know we're going to the other X yeah
oh wait no do we have all three pieces
that three pieces oh yeah go to the
other X you're right I don't know why
there would be an X there if they don't
want me to go there
all right that's a wall sorry wasn't
paying attention
hey I warned me about the bonds forgot
how dumb this game is hold on now you're
good just go yeah go through here it's
gonna be some some more bombs probably I
would imagine I'll be shooting them I'll
try
you can probably slow down a little bit
let me scope this out this tower
stopping to be on the way out if to go
into bonds
nope clear but
wait where's the drip doc
I think you did mess up each other okay
for fun this is nice
take the scenic route yeah sweet keep an
eye out for slates you got it girl
pshh horse horse their rustic from back
up don't go don't go for that they have
so much
yeah okay here wait come here back up
more I'm gonna back up back up back up
back up back oh you're gonna get blown
up let me watch this thing I did watch
all little pieces
there's a guy down here here - oh no
he's following you he was a few guys go
what's wrong
I'm very good I'm not near you
you he's got like [ __ ] kind of shut up
you're [ __ ] up
I'm alright just getting [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] has a guy right next week and I'm
not oh man I guess got spirit
I got takes green herb and go use it um
don't you ever read herb yeah but I
don't know if I have time to combine it
right now you do come up in to cover me
yep there's a lot sorry I wasn't [ __ ] he
threw a [ __ ] at me I'm actually not
doing we're coming from the window next
to you my watch your bag oh my god
they're jumping all over the place oh my
god I'm in a lot of trouble
oh I see I see there's like 20 of them
that's next to me do you really like um
come on
I'm throwing a grenade okay I miss shut
up didn't like that window behind you
you've helped reason oh yeah I picked up
an urn we're almost to the other thing
yeah how'd you see that that way was
glitter that was cool [ __ ] him get out
of my [ __ ] airspace [ __ ]
I was gonna whoa I didn't know you at
the shotgun I thought something blew up
ooh
I'll stab it to double's stomping stab
well that was a lot of dudes I don't
have anything to Haley with I'm an egg
oh you have a red and green you good
mine
I have just picked that up or something
I did a dead guy dropped it sweet
there's that slate down there if you
want to get but there's a whole other
building we didn't really explore or use
but hmm oh no it's in here I think wait
was this one so trap okay so I have I
just got a slate okay I'm gonna take
this thing up no no okay that wasn't
should I use this I got the sleeve do
you want any of it
what it's all for me um nah I'm full I
feel like we're not using these properly
but I don't form literally full it
wouldn't matter
yeah I just didn't have I was it was in
the heat of the moment I use my other
one so I didn't have time to come up the
walk next to you you should reload it's
making me nervous that you might forget
in the future okay
um where would you like to go back to
the boat back to the door oh we're done
I got the sleep it was over in a
separate building do you have all the
pieces Hey
[Music]
I also do I click the left stick twice I
don't know what that thing is
yeah that's weird
um of course hate that noise like why
did they do little ping
it seems reasonable be constant
get on girlfriend I'm gonna take you
places by you thing
Dennett stop and smell the flowers Sheva
oh how sweet home sweet uh try to keep
it as steady as possible so I can snipe
some dudes
got one no joke I got it Oh
maybe up.wake nope oh [ __ ] well you
should like warned me I there wasn't
stop I can't really I like to think I
get hit all them on the move like this I
can't
that's cool I saw that needs to be doing
yeah I think we need to kill them before
the door opens great they're straight on
and at Tower 2
[Music]
I'm a term then this guy wait on hunch
yes huh this guy this jerk right here
shot the other one first this guy
this guy
wait stop right here stopper here what
is that it's a fun don't go inch forward
okay wait
h4 that's not oh [ __ ] you throw one Oh
got him nice a sari nice week
and then I guess for what's that with
that just can I hit them uh it might
blow up their farm arrows [ __ ] breath
for a while I got him I got him
go on
like why would you in the water to shoot
me like it's so dangerous for you
I don't think Safety's been their main
concern this whole game yet I haven't
like considered their own lives we did
it we did it
remember through oh well James Marcus no
no I don't like going into the water
not after the alligator thing
is there not crocodiles
damn this parts really dumb and crazy
what is this just a [ __ ] village
assault filled with minds a mind mate
collet I don't know if we should walk in
these let's try it out
hi guys
what did we learn there's a guy missing
on your screen
oh I got a magnum whoa how do i oh yeah
going I'm coming I forgot about this
part thank you
repel this guy nope too late
I think hopefully what you learned was
to not jump over that stuff whatever
kind of Magnum do you want it I'm not
gonna use it
mm I'll give it to you sure oh I want to
give you this I can't I can't give you a
gun yet maybe actually okay now go ahead
I think I said wait till the menus word
really I can give you things maybe not
weapons though I don't know Robin where
are they everywhere
oh you are super dead come on this way
go upstairs just are one for me yes
upstairs would be the right direction
well how do you miss me these guys with
the masks are coming no Jesus god damn
it oh my god the big dude
get the [ __ ] out of my way there's a big
dude coming know where you are
oh look at how big that guy's whoa
there's two of them get up here in sendo
away well that's smart
how did you just let that fence in a
single panel if I have anything else am
I excused all right you know what else
am I have a good wrap here let me isn't
mine I have a grenade just come here
come this way
you know they have no armor on nice no
son like that
come on Magnum yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how are they still alive
jump down you can jump down off yeah
jump down behind you oh [ __ ] wait
there's that more out of the spikes oh
is that what we're supposed to be honey
we're gonna kill him either way but yeah
get out of there I am in the danger zone
here her r1 shows where I am
I just meant I'm getting [ __ ] up I
like don't have any ho
oh my God we're gonna oh okay back I'm
time I have a grenade left should I use
it yes okay well I'm gonna be dead uh
yeah just keep running remember there's
a better way to do this probably is as
usual but yeah come up here don't don't
kind of standard fight them like that
all those guys in here - lets go up go
up go up where hold r1 to show you I
know where you are I mean I just like
there's guys like on your buns oh Jesus
you really didn't follow me okay [ __ ]
him Rico this guy first
he's dead give me some give me some
sugar I'm hiding they kind of split up
ones after me the others with you well I
just need this dude die
Wow I'm gonna die I was a green herb
over here that just dropped near my
mommy there's too many there's two there
really is that's kind of that is there a
different way to kill these guys in the
module there has to be I'm out of like
all right ones that ones that one said
oh my goodness there's a lot of dudes
there's so many there's a lot going on
here
there's a green herb of are you gonna
pick out that just die
you're wearing a rope for underwear kick
him punch
ruff hey guys these little things
there's sticks oh I think he just I'm
going back to my old dude this is
there's a green herb down near okay
follow me the greener to jump down when
I um I see you
alright I'm gonna do it just kill it
thank you I think the other ones might
just be coming really I really don't
know
just use that right now oh crap
I think the shocking table sorry that's
fine hi you accidentally took your ammo
mystery area there's a who's this please
who uses a no-bullshit whoops I'm dying
sorry okay come here
so oh just come press circle on me oh
we're [ __ ]
never not never not so all right I
understand you're supposed to run past
those spikes and trigger them no it
kills you a peasant listener no you just
stood on them for too long I already
killed one of the guys they can just die
and normally I just use my you're
supposed to run past the spikes in here
I already look okay I killed one of them
normally he's over here I know but I'm
saying you can also run on those spike
stick it makes sense
I don't like you're not wrong they're
[ __ ] is dead a Mega Man
there's so many of these [ __ ] almost
there
oh my god get out of those you gotta
hide you can't hide Oh later Nathan
needed your clothes though we're
definitely close coming oh yeah how's
that almost find you [ __ ] come out of
everything
you're probably right we probably did
not do that efficiently but there's this
[ __ ] everybody's pick it up I got
machine gun for you here come here oh
man
didn't did it over still got our egg
there's always that no I think what
we're supposed to do is go around the
left side and have them lure into those
because I don't think they trigger more
than once I could be wrong about that
but whatever they made it through odd
that didn't go well at all Magnum ammo I
might get you Magnum although I don't
know if I I don't have a Magnum I might
after might give you the Magnum itself
nothing much don't walk on those okay
see I don't think they trigger after all
right uh sorry dad guide what I said you
I got I killed both of those guys I know
Lee yell okay I forgot you were the only
one shooting up him red or the ultimate
like I loosened it for you
jar open guy mega memo
hang on mo you really should
a lot of hand guy ammo I see no evidence
of it I'm taking all of it
look I have 39 handgun rounds let me
give you your shotgun shell swear you
that I see you also have a red and green
herb I have a red and green herb and a
green herb oh here say so Drive shotgun
shells no put out let's heal up
might as well okay sweet all right come
on
well that got out of hand fast yeah
didn't go very long but uh a letter
there um didn't make it
oh my God he's dead
this is where we were supposed to go oh
no that's the winch for the drawbridge
yeah use that thing
I found the winch winch Oh
do you not really sit well on it cuz
that really funny but don't do it the
[ __ ] is wrong with you oh I thought you
cause was to to do again hey we got a
checkpoint
I watched you cross yeah I was still
standing on the bridge it's not
half-life 2 but there's a physics engine
it play man you ready here we go
I overreacted sorry hey press square
okay now you can press it Joe Oh Chris
open up this door Oh snake
[ __ ] you oh man I'm sorry oh there's two
things oh sweet damn it did you get hit
No
um yep come on it see ya oh sweet here
I'll help you out
Thanks Oh shotgun shells over here cool
a lot of stuff over here actually uh
handgun ammo over here you want to swap
sees surely pick up I got a green herb I
can combine quick movie shot enjoy read
the document village eats diary I don't
care how much do we care about starting
this wow this is a long diary it's like
seven pages you know this story in this
game has been about as enjoyable as the
boss fights not nice good nacho
not this is money this way like I was
thinking about that boss fight we did
the other day and it's just really bad
what do you think of an incinerator one
the first one oh I think that one's
really cool because like you get these
other op re time with the one where you
like have to like slide down and when
you open up the lever I don't know if or
circle I'm talking about I'm talking
about in this game the beginning to do
that you almost burn me alive in the
furnace room are we gonna play lots of
nightmares no I don't think so not right
now
sweet options okay uh it's working at
some [ __ ] at a lot of all right easy
sure you got some machine gun where you
can combine with your machine gun
alright so I'm keeping the egg Jesse for
weapons I don't need this Magnum right
now let me sell my oh oh it's thirty my
ultimate rifle one rifle shotgun just
wanna go find that shock on them
treasures see only a lot of stuffs so
both of these
so all your treasures son oh okay an
ancient Idol
I sold fat and the ceremony mass mony
old man
okay what about you don't I also don't
know if any of the stuff combines I
don't think it does
like there's no option to combine it so
you sell it all cuz the mask has like a
hole in it I don't know I already sold
it though me to feel like we didn't
think this through cuz like look at the
mask it's clearly got two holes missing
must be derelict um
upgrade stuff I guess what about these
hearts yeah tell those to upgrade my
handgun
is there anything cool to buy besides
weapons or we just buying weapons I mean
there's a melee of s but I don't really
write because it takes a slot right I
have all this money and I don't really
know what to do with the never my rifle
did you have a better rifle than what I
have yeah should I buy a magnum or what
oh wait I could just give you mine I
think we try maybe you can't give
weapons
movemove
okay I can cuz like I didn't give ya
animal I just I'm gonna get weapons you
get it it might be worth violence I'm
not gonna use mine right now
I have Magnum ammo though is it the SMW
m25 yeah I just I have three guns
already I have a shotgun for when they
get too close to me
you only yeah I have the I would bring a
handgun a few I would buy it invest in a
handgun and then instead of taking the
rifle I mean I don't think to both of us
need a rifle
the handgun you get a lot of AM before
it's practical you can shoot them the
legs and then punch them right now
you're just using salt except for the
mp5 using like all power weapons kind of
that's right
I would you could buy angle there's a
decent the USP or whatever it is the
agent kPa is good PA it's up to you if
you feel comfortable the weapons you
have and just roll with that I like my
weapons okay let's go but I haven't like
upgraded them in a really long time
I'm upgrade to shotgun OFS
whatever I'm not doing anything else
with my life don't feel like the reload
speeds that important like what am I
going to do at that point one five
seconds I mean it builds yeah 23000 role
to spend it's gonna be more than 0.3 1
seconds oh [ __ ] sorry it's coming down
you're good I'm fine right I'm just
decking around I'm not really good at
this part like the whole like here's
some money go buy stuff with it I just
kind of like mess around and like buy
whatever I don't really think I think it
through we'll put a lot of consideration
into it at all
and it should be a really important part
but I'm just not always into it oops I
triggered something
[Music]
afraid of alligators now come over here
boy never ing witchy tozi Rosie's high
when we up to I getting into
um so there's two handgun a mows down
here
oh [ __ ] was that it was a bomb we should
probably move them I'm not sure oh I see
it all right I'm working on it all right
here here here you you got the shotgun
you take care of
so I have piercing ammo on my handgun
now our upgraded piercing second oh I
got to stop picking things up
Oh for [ __ ] sake really Harris about
don't worry about this actually yeah you
know you do need to worry about it and
not him I'm not talking about you you
are inconsistent I'm not talking about
him I was talking don't about the ammo
you were like use your shotgun on these
guys instead of taking out the bomb guys
but the by talking about something my
buns so kill them I'm just saying don't
worry about the ammo until we're done
you just picked up ammo in the middle of
a fight yeah I said I didn't like it
yeah you know I feel like you're not
listening
you're like I'm you're not that good at
this yeah we know that I'm just kidding
oh but [ __ ]
Oh somebody's shooting at me
they're shooting at me this is
ridiculous gosh I still shopping I can
see you're safe
oh alright coming from over here I found
us he's gonna go on it
come on right huh
where's that guy we were trying to kill
prep found him prep see a couple yeah
the problem is being followed
Jimmy to help you coming oh Jesus
he dead okay good he's dead I'm coming
over to help you stomp stomp clap clap
that's bondage that you kill him oh I
killed one don't know how many there
were
I know he's gotta go to that winch again
right here I got to do this one why you
go over um what is that noise oh you
gotta get on that rock over there side I
hear it hold on
it sounds like someone breathing into
the mic I know I'm not I'm definitely
not doing it like it I know you're not
I'm just saying it is there an alligator
like a dead is there a dude who got
stuck no cuz in the scary music with you
no I mean like this is audio stuck on
only you got to get on a ship um there's
a raft yeah I get on that alright I'm
doing a second scene you're gonna have
to do some shooting I think while you're
on that alligator a snake maybe that is
stuck on an audio loop that's really
annoying okay all right
you ready oh god I got a checkpoint
right
alligator gonna come up at you I don't
know you might have to protect me what
that noise was jeez
anybody's wondering I'm turning my life
she
there's a ladder coming up oh go go go
he wants to eat me hit that thing next
to you okay you know hit the there's a
button over there
um near where you got off the raft oh oh
kicks everything kick says zebra what is
that zebra Circle he just kicked zebra
circle um okay
maybe I'll just trigger if I go you want
the word about coming back here I
honestly don't want you anywhere near me
and drawbridges anymore well never know
alright I'm waiting here in this tunnel
um oh so I just go back the way I came
yeah yeah uh no here right right here
well originally came here yeah
that noise rap just going back in place
silly section it's just like hazily and
other ones it kind of felt like this
style of the area's benefited the
gameplay like it worked together but
these feel like they were constructed
specifically you know like I don't know
[ __ ] sorry hon there's a jewel in this
thing oh I see it good eye right next my
face everything feels like a setup how
about that does that make pieces as
opposed to more emergent stuff happening
yeah I don't feel like organically like
I'm playing like why does that system
work like why did they have it why would
they make you poles mean resevoir did a
lot of that too but they took this to
the 10th degree found a jewel beetle
there's a clipboard over here if you
feel like reading it farther still found
a birthday there's no las Plagas at a
specialty
uh handgun ammo over here come on
hmm
this looks like it's gonna be important
this fire shooting out over this oil it
all feel Oh snake in the grass snake
side too awful three of us know so right
in my bed
you had an awful dream in your bed no
like a dream it was a waking dream and
in my waking dream there were snakes in
my real life bed ah sounds awful I had a
lot of those kind of jigs waking dreams
I was at the oil field yeah and Irving's
not getting away this to your night
terrors those are different
now it just gets all industrial yeah
look what it's crazy different there's
always a lab right but we were like I
don't want who's parter Yeah right
as far as a lot of dudes again
oh [ __ ]
Oh God
[Applause]
yeah much
[ __ ] to do with a crossbow summer
right here come up here
oh no that guy has dynamite turning
something I don't know what I'm doing
alright solved anything useful okay so
I'm turning the fire off sweet Oh
should I've done that yet doesn't matter
yeah give me a chance on you soon I'd
send your grenade up here where I am
[ __ ]
Oh Kelly's cross don't
well that's annoying
how's it going over here good oh I
didn't mean to jump down don't oh you
should have told Joey I should have yeah
I'm like to see you super close to death
I am up here doing my job is it is your
job to be defensive I should you should
cuz you're doing a great job
you just blamed me I don't like even
blaming it's gonna happen oh I'm super
close to death
I've got dynamite where are you get this
[ __ ] cells you die
so he'll don't you have yeah but you
should heal with me come over here
[Music]
or can I jump across here okay just heal
now
got the narrow I'm put aside there's
this section where I feel like I should
get across here oh you know what I'm
supposed to jump I'm supposed to push
you over here I gotta pull this lever
hold on hold on hold on they don't come
back up to where you were just so you
can get past those going toward these
flames over here right nope other right
there okay
how long do I get it turns off really
that's what I turn I turn off the first
[ __ ] oh he's right next to me I hope you
guys come over here might need to are
you gonna do it or not if he comes at me
right now and no I might have time all
right I got a mine down so that should
all right you ready goo you might be
coming for you I hope no no he's here
he's here oh [ __ ]
so I'm in his but [ __ ] yeah I'll get
back up just a second
keep shooting you came up not to beat
down I'm nowhere near him yet
right now I can't
reset a little bit here you want to do
the lever and I'll cover you
you'll need to go get the lever oh my
god I don't do anybody come this way let
him learn you over here I got a mind for
him
come this way no not that way he's
coming - are you alright I'm gonna go be
the lever you just keep running around
and what if I'm running into like a dead
ends I ran into a dead end just God he's
not that hard to dodge I think he's
gonna hurt me right now
he definitely Oh God come on hurry up Oh
this tipline is not hurry minds can
hurry okay all right I'm coming up use
that
where are you back toward the all right
get ready got this planned okay I'm
ready nope
well I mean you have timers nice good uh
we gotta get a good alright now let's we
can I don't you know what the point of
do that would be probably gonna kill him
I just want to make sure we have more
room run
hey I got it I'll put a mine down over
here come here okay
yeah
he's coming 300
[Music]
Rizzy
of her toward me
yeah yeah you're dead sir oh there's a
whole nother lever
um over day Oh was that a dead end that
on that door oh yes it was um yeah it
was her get into the other lover I got
it but I didn't understand at the time
and I never cared cuz there there was a
chainsaw guy it's a dead end of the veil
the levers up here I'm pulling the zip
line up here I'll get the flames
look at me hold r2
all right I missed it so my feet
thank you machine gun mo you weren't
looking dad
Wow she looks like a spaz when she does
that uh
uh oh my god
a lot of [ __ ] happen okay why is it oh
my god
this guy's right next to me this over
here turn around
pop
there's another chance like I ever near
me but I'm coming toward you there's
another chainsaw guy yeah did you not
get that cutting I mean I just assumed
that to gain made a mistake yeah just
come in though to me no no to me but I'm
good
now great
three up me no the reload
Oh
you're gonna [ __ ] that what's that do
chance I didn't behind if you couldn't
kill mine shooting in
this after there's a mutation thing
behind me too
yeah that was my bad oh [ __ ] man I'm not
good at covering in John actually cuz I
can tell the other one
this [ __ ] meat Kate meat anything
will die he grenades saw a bunch of
giblets hit the sky with that
but toe-to-toe with you [ __ ]
come here
[Music]
I'll kill you with the right point-blank
or even feeling okay what I mean I know
I'm indifferent and just shooting things
and not very well
oh [ __ ] I got caught on it
my god I
please we didn't use a mine on him
that's why wow this guy's are really
easy to dodge actually okay I gotta take
my egg off it'll quit like a right
sloppy eating it on accident here's some
machine video oh thanks
oh thank you oh okay Red Hawk are they
two making sure I'm Jackyl
it's javelin well thank Mikey hey Mikey
all right good job that went smoothly
um for the most part yeah look a good
time to call this when you stop doing
that
I don't understand sweet
what are you thinking this game it's my
least favorite even after your
experiment spigarello watch sa-something
Irving or was it bad
or gmask a person
Josh Shiva you alive are you okay
what how did you get here we were at the
portal we were attacked and then well I
ended up here double crop there the team
yeah there's the worst lie ever [ __ ]
it's just the three of us now why did
you never cheat I mean we are no match
with him I've got unfinished business
the hard drive containing dis none of
your business
Josh it's funny that they called him
Josh Mitchell isn't Chris's I call him
Mikey if you had a name I'll read
anemone I'm not leaving until I catch
herbing and find out what the hell's
going on here oh let's save the chitchat
for later
save you
and we'll shot that
zipper cover me hurry
packs faster yeah
no cover me now it'll be gone but not
place
let's start roof I'm not playing I'm I'm
on our don't with yup so Mary David I'm
doing really well
are you sure yes yes do it do it all
right
really uncomfortable don't care sweet uh
okay sounds good up so I kept going uh
yeah really stressful wait end don't
start from the that's it yeah we got
check warning or it might start right
before it I hope so um yes at the leak
good night your parents are in town yes
my parents are in San Francisco we're
gonna play a resonable sticks together
we're not I wouldn't do that to you Mary
or my parents yeah seriously I don't
know if anyone like looks forward to
that nope uh cool sweet see you on the
next resident
Giannini hi everyone from resident
Kamini sounds like something the bad guy
would say welcome to my resident can
eeny please don't you